[Musique]
valérie pécresse on veut faire de la
région ile-de-france un hub mondial de
l'innovation et on veut devenir la
première smart régions d'europe et dans
ce cadre là on a décidé d'organiser les
paris serait jane smart weeks donc les
semaines de la région intelligente 2018
qui est toute une série d'événements
tout au long de l'année avec un focus en
mai juin ou notamment on aura
l'événement paris-saclay spring et le
but c'est vraiment de mettre en avant
toutes nos entreprises nos startups et
nos pépites technologiques à la fois
destination des entreprises et mais
aussi du grand public pour qu'il
découvre vraiment tous nos atouts en
termes de filières stratégiques clés
qu'on a identifié à la région tels que
la médecine du futur la cybersécurité la
robotique
l'intelligence artificielle sur lesquels
on travaille déjà énormément par
d'autres dispositifs régionaux ce qui
concerne le public de ces événements il
ya toute une série d'événements donc qui
ont des publics différents il y en a
certains pour le grand public mais c'est
plus particulièrement quand même à
destination des entreprises nationales
mais également internationale tout ce
qu'on fait on est dans une politique
d'attractivité la région et on veut
donner à voir au monde entier tous ses
atouts qui sont les nôtres notamment sur
paris saclay on a toute une série
d'événements mais pas que des événements
puisque on soutient également d'autres
projets très structurant pour la région
en termes d'innovation je pense sur
saclay par exemple digi hall qui a
vocation à être un centre vraiment à
vocation internationale sur
l'intelligence artificielle dans ce
cadre là d'ailleurs on a lancé aussi le
premier challenge international sur
l'intelligence artificielle très
récemment qui court jusqu'au 17 juin
on a aussi à paris saclay
d'autres évènements que l'on soutient et
d'autres structures que l'on soutient
tel que l'a dit et factory hub sur la
fabrication 3d est donc vraiment il ya
tout un ensemble d'actions qui crée cet
écosystème très positif et qui a
vocation à faire briller la région au
niveau international